we're told suppose suppose a plus b is
equal to 2a
which of these expressions equals b
minus a
all right i encourage you to pause the
video and see if you can figure that out
which of these expressions would be
equal to b
minus a and it's going to just involve
some some algebraic manipulation
all right let's let's work through this
together so we are told
we are told that a plus b
is equal to 2 a
so the first thing i would want to do is
get all my a's in one place and one way
i could do that is i could subtract a
from both sides so if i subtract a
from both sides i'm going to be left
with just a b on the left hand side and
on the right hand side i'm going to be
left with 2a minus a well that's just
going to be a if i have 2 of something
and i subtract 1 of them take away 1 of
them i'm going to have just one of those
something it's going to be equal to 1a
so we want to figure out what b minus a
is
well luckily i can figure that out if i
subtract a from both sides so if i
subtract a
from both sides
well then i'm going to get on the left
hand side b minus a which is what we
want to figure out is equal to a minus a
is equal to zero so b minus a is equal
to
zero
which is not
one of the choices all right so let's
let's see if we can if we can figure out
some other things over here so b minus a
is equal to zero but that is not
one of the choices all right so let's
see is there other any other way to
manipulate this no b might if i i could
just go straight ahead and subtract 2a
from both sides and i would get b minus
a is equal to zero
oh this is interesting this is a tricky
one so b minus a
is zero
well if b minus a is equal to zero then
if we take the negative of both sides of
this
if we take the negative of both sides if
we multiply both sides by negative
so times
i should write i should write the times
i should write like this all right
because we don't want to confuse it with
the variable x so if we multiply both
sides by negative 1 what do we get well
on the left hand side we get a minus b
and on the right hand side we still get
a zero if b minus a is zero then the
negative of it which is a minus b is
also going to be equal to zero and
that's this choice
that is let me do that a little darker
color that is this choice
right over there that was that was a
good one